i try to remove the kind of taboo or the
negative associations we have with the
word like power or with the word
ambition you know i try and say ambition
is a good thing it means that you have
you believed in yourself you you have
some self love and you believe you're
worth something and you want to go out
and achieve and it creates something
worthwhile for other people so ambition
is a positive thing but so many people
are just kind of embarrassed about being
a human being embarrassed about our
primate nature embarrassed about our own
aggressive impulses this is partly why
boys are failing in our schools now at a
disproportionate rate you know the and i
see this there's an assault of the sort
that you're describing on the better
part of striving masculinity and you
know i had a friend who killed himself
because he identified his ambition with
you know the the
patriarchal force that's devouring the
environment let's say and that's a con
that's you know the cause of of
historical horror and you might say well
no one takes that on to themselves to
that degree and that's well you can say
that but that you just don't know what
the hell you're talking about people
take that on to themselves all the time
[Music]
hi everyone i'm pleased today to have
with me mr robert greene mr grain is the
number one new york times best-selling
author of number of books the 48 laws of
power 1998 the art of seduction
2001 the 33 strategies of war 2007 the
50th law which he wrote with 50 cent the
rapper 2008
mastery 2012 the laws of human nature
2018 and the daily laws this book right
here
so
he's an
he's an internationally renowned expert
on power strategies living in los
angeles mr greene worked at an estimated
80 jobs including magazine editor
construction worker hollywood movie
writer before becoming an author
the sunday times referred to
his first book the 48 laws of power as
the hollywood backstabbers bible and it
can be difficult to find people who
acknowledge its influence because of its
controversial nature i was reading
the daily laws before setting up this
interview and i'm going to read
one yeah it's a it's a set of
meditations 366 meditations on power
seduction mastery strategy and human
nature and so here's the one for
june 7th and i think it's relatively
representative
of the book
june 7th never impugn people's
intelligence
then there's a subtitle uh or an
introductory idea the best way to be
well received by all is to clothe
yourself
in the skin of the dumbest of brutes
balthasar gracian
the feeling that someone else is more
intelligent than we are is almost always
intolerable
we usually try to justify it in
different ways quote he only has book
knowledge whereas i have real knowledge
quote her parents paid for her to get a
good education if my parents had had as
much money if i had been as privileged
he's not as smart as he thinks
last but not least quote she may know
her narrow little field better than i do
but beyond that she's really not smart
at all even einstein was a boob outside
physics
given how important the idea of
intelligence is to most people's vanity
it is critical never inadvertently to
insult or impugn a person's brainpower
this is an unforgivable sin
but if you can make this iron rule work
for you it opens up all sorts of avenues
of deception
the feeling of intellectual superiority
you give them will disarm their
suspicion muscles
and then
daily law
subliminally reassure people that they
are more intelligent than you are or
even that you are a bit of a [ __ ] and
you can run rings around them
and this is the 48 laws of power from
the 48 levels of power law 21 play a
sucker to catch a sucker seem dumber
than your mark
so when i was preparing for this
i was reading these daily
um
these daily meditations and i was
actually shocked i was really quite
shocked by them i was shocked by that
one and i was very unclear as a
consequence
as to your motivations and so i was
thinking do i wanna do i wanna i don't
get this i don't understand this exactly
it's like this is very deceptive and
then i talk to my team
who like your books a lot and
and my daughter who really liked
interviewing you and i thought well
there's something going on here that i
don't quite understand which is
certainly possible and then i thought
well
this is maybe a shadow exploration
something like that yes and then i
thought like i was kind of a dimwit for
not catching that earlier but so but you
know it is shocking these are very
manipulative uh laws let's say and so
can you guide me through
the rationale for producing material
like that
what were you trying what are you trying
to do with your books and they've
obviously been misunderstood it says in
the in wikipedia green's books are
sometimes described as manipulative and
amoral and so
clear this up for me well you know that
it's a it's a bit manipulative when
people write that because a great deal
of the 48 laws of power i'd say you know
maybe two-thirds of them are not
manipulative have nothing to do with
deception they have things to do with
kind of common sense ideas about power
such as such as being generous with
people such as creating compelling
spectacles
such as entering action with boldness
and kind of how you present yourself
sort of things about your image and your
appearance but there are definitely some
laws that are quite manipulative and
then my other books don't really go into
things like that so it is a bit of a
distortion to write that
but where this comes from
is basically um i have a particular idea
of power so maybe i should explain that
a little bit
my idea of power it's not about this
kind of grand thing of political or war
something it's on a very individual
level
and the idea for me comes from from
nietzsche and his idea of the will to
power which he explains as all every
organism has the desire to expand itself
as a desire for expansion
and so i think that for human beings the
desire that we we have this innate uh
propensity for wanting to expand beyond
our limits we want to feel
like we have some degree
of ability to influence other people
that we can control our own career and
learn more and develop greater skills
and have more kind of power and
influence in our life the feeling that i
cannot have any power or influence over
my children my spouse my colleagues my
boss
my career in general is deeply deeply
unsettling for the human animal and
causes all kinds of attempts at what i
call negative power
passive aggression etc
setting yourself up as a victim's kind
of leverage power in a negative way and
so
the problem is
um and i this a lot of this comes from
machiavelli who inspired a lot of the 48
laws
the problem is that we live in a world
where this desire for some kind of power
butts up against
kind of codes of behavior that have
gotten stricter and stricter and
stricter in in particular in the 21st
century
about what is acceptable about what is
politically correct so we're supposed to
appear to be these paragons of virtue
these paragraphs of fairness and
democracy etc at the same time we're all
trying to angle for different degrees of
power in our work in our relationships
etc and so
because of that dynamic we have to be
extremely careful in this world and i
compare it to the courts
of like louis xiv
where all of the courtiers if they're
too overt in their power moves the king
will disapprove of them and will not
banish them but they'll be kind of
excluded to the corner of the palace and
so the game was to be sort of indirect
to be polite and ingratiating and if you
had an enemy to know how to kind of very
quietly get rid of them
and so
this is kind of uh what i would
what kid where the 48 laws of power came
out from so you quoted me i had like 80
different jobs probably more like 60 65
but i saw all kinds of very
deceptive games being played continually
in the various different jobs i had and
i i worked in every conceivable field
and
i didn't see any kind of honesty about
this dynamic in the human world and it
really kind of irritated me all the
self-help books were sort of
describing a world that i never saw
existed you know i saw people being very
political having egos and having
problems with their egos
and i didn't see anybody any books like
they're kind of describing what i had
encountered every day
so law number one is never outshine the
master
and the idea is that if you try too hard
to impress your boss or the person above
you you're liable to make them feel
insecure you're gonna trip on their ego
and something bad will happen to you
right and so this seemed like
the fact that people have egos and
operate with egos and you have to be
careful with them seems very clear to me
but i didn't find books out there that
were describing it
so i hope this kind of gives you an idea
a little bit of the context where the
book came out okay yeah well the okay so
i just i i can't remember who sent me
this uh
i think it was clay routledge yeah i
think that's right
he just sent me a survey that this
organization he works with has
completed
stating that something like 40 percent
of millennials don't feel they have any
control over their life
right so that is related to the first
issue that you brought up and
and
you you obviously consider that uh
problematic and you said that well we
need to
it's good for us to have some control
over our destinies and also to feel that
that's a possibility to see it at least
as a goal yes and then and that if
if we
feel consciously
thwarted in that goal or believe that
it's impossible that doesn't mean we're
going to give up our striving it means
it's going to go underground and then
it's going to manifest itself in all
sorts of deceptive ways
and then you you said that
you were interested in nietzsche's idea
of will to power as in some sense the
central motivating uh the central
motivation of of the organism yeah
across species to some degree
um
and then you talked about the jobs that
you've had so why why did so i got that
right i hope i i hope i've got it that
was very well thank you okay okay and so
and so to some degree and then you said
well you had all these jobs and you
found that people were engaged in
manipulative and deceptive strategies a
fair number of
a fair amount of the time and that no
one was really warning people about this
or delineating out the strategies yeah
okay so that you know that seems to me
to be reasonable that
i mean i'm a big admirer of the work of
carl jung which everyone listening to
this knows more than they even want to
know
and he was certainly
sensitive
to the idea that people had a terrible
shadow yes that
they would clothe themselves in the
garments of moral virtue right and act
out a virtuous persona but because of
the thwarted
will to strive in some sense that
they have all sorts of motivations
sexual power related dominance um
aggression anger resentment that aren't
admitted thoroughly and that are snakes
under the carpet or elephants under the
rug or skeletons in the closet and they
pollute human relationships and i
certainly believe that's true i believe
that that that's
the corruption of human relationships by
a form of
of severe deceit and i also think it's
reasonable to warn people against that
and also to alert them to the fact that
such things operate in their own souls
i guess what i wonder is
so then the last thing i'm confused
about to some degree is
you had 65 jobs how come so many jobs
i was a very restless young man it
doesn't speak very well of me and the
fact that i couldn't hold a job for more
than 11 months
i came out of college and i wanted to be
a writer and i had all kinds of romantic
notions of what that meant
and then i entered journalism and i
worked in new york and i didn't find
that that was a very good fit so i
moved to europe and i wandered around
for four or five years writing trying to
write novels and working in hotels doing
construction
kind of the writer's life where the the
the variety of experiences were kind of
giving me material
and i couldn't i never was really happy
in in overtly political environments to
be honest with you i'm kind of a born
entrepreneur i like working for myself i
didn't like
a lot of the games that were being
played and i'm not very good at them i
mean i've gotten better at it but a lot
of the things that i write about in the
48 laws of power such as never outshine
the master are things that i did poorly
i did wrong and i suffered for them so i
understand the kind of the pain that a
lot of people have in the work world
which is sort of hard for a lot of other
people who don't have that kind of
experience to understand how deeply
frustrating it can be when you have a
job that you're not satisfied with and
so i was someone who was very restless
and i never felt comfortable in any of
the different jobs i had and i was also
trying to broaden my experience okay so
so i had a lot of jobs when i was a kid
i worked as a
oh god i worked as an uh
in a garage pumping gas i worked as a
dishwasher for years i was a short order
cook
i tip drill bits i worked as a beekeeper
i had a lot of oh i worked in a plywood
mill uh running plywood pieces through a
huge dryer we used to try to light the
thing on fire it was like a block long
this dryer fired by natural gas if you
worked really hard you could stuff it so
full it would get crammed up in the
middle and then it would light on fire
and all the the fire uh
sprinklers would kick in and then the
whole building which was like a block
square would fill up with steam
so anyways i worked in a lot of jobs and
and so but
i didn't
so this is something that's worth
getting clear
i liked the jobs a lot almost all of
them not all of them but almost all of
them i got along with the people that i
was working with i didn't have the same
ex exactly the same experience that
you're describing and yeah you said that
you said that you had a harder time i
don't know exactly was it fitting in you
didn't like overt the political elements
too
and like when i worked in restaurants
i didn't really experience that you know
like i got along with the guys that i
was working with there was a lot of
joking around i i and it's not like i
like political maneuvering when i got
into university and saw people in
bureaucracies particularly maneuvering
politically to attain dominance just i
found it i didn't know i find it
absolutely appalling that underground
power struggle but it sounds like
it sounds like you had a harder time
maybe than i did
adapting and that maybe
is and that became a conscious puzzle
for you is that a reasonable way of
thinking about it i think so it made me
explore think about myself like maybe
i'm doing something wrong the natural
reaction in these situations
where things you know it wasn't that i
hated all of my job some of them were
fonts i don't want to give the wrong
impression but when mistakes were made
and i it may be inadvertently made of my
boss or someone feel insecure
it caused me like months later to kind
of question what had happened and maybe
something i did that was wrong in that
environment
and so um
you know i i felt
it wasn't that i felt uncomfortable but
i felt sometimes
that trying so hard or being good at my
job which was often the case was often
the detriment which was a very strange
realization well that's so that that's a
really good sign that you need to go get
a different job i mean i worked with
clinical clients a lot a lot you know
in career counseling
and my sense one of the things we'd
analyzed right away was well can you
actually do your job well and be
recognized for it and have a pathway to
something approximating success or are
you around truly toxic people who will
punish you for your virtues in which
case let's get your cv together you know
let's get you prepared to get the hell
out of there and find a place where you
can actually thrive i mean i had clients
who were trapped in jobs
i remember one client in particular shia
she had been a refugee from albania
eastern europe that was a rough damn
country man and then she came yeah yeah
like the worst of the eastern european
countries in terms of poverty and
general oppressiveness and then she came
over to
north america and got educated she ended
up working in a bank in canada and
like she was good at her job and she was
smart and
her managers just hated her and like she
sent me an email string one day it was
about 30 emails long that her manager
had put together where the bureaucrats
in the bank were discussing whether or
not they were allowed anymore to use the
word flip chart
i think they replaced it with easel
board or some damn thing well the reason
for that was
flip had been used at some point
hypothetically as an epithet for
filipino people and so it was it was
politically incorrect and it was just i
mean she was just being driven mad by
this this kind of
what would you call it pointless moral
posturing and she was a sensible person
and questioned a lot of the bureaucratic
stupidity so right my goal in situations
like that was to help people figure out
how to move laterally and find a place
where
you know their virtues would be rewarded
instead of punished right it's very wise
you know yeah it can be managed
my experience is um and what i wanted to
help people with 48 laws of power when
these things kind of happen you get very
confused and they create a kind of
trauma in your life where you sometimes
blame yourself or you wonder maybe you
did something wrong
and
you become a little bit skittish
and you you you get a little bit afraid
in your next job and these things kind
of linger on in your mind so having some
clarity
i don't want to make people paranoid in
reading these books i make it very clear
that that's not the point i want you to
be very realistic but the idea that you
could have some clarity that maybe what
really happened is that i inadvertently
triggered the insecurities of this boss
or maybe they're these strict kind of
moral puritanical codes in place
and i somehow violated them it's not my
fault
that kind of clarity can be very very
empowering i find in that that's another
kind of motivating device behind the 48
laws well you also make me very curious
about your personality i mean when i'm
talking i'm sorry i'm gonna yeah well
you know
that's okay i'm a clinician and i snap
into that mode sometimes and i'm very
curious about this conversation you have
a very gentle demeanor and a very uh
soft and kind voice and yeah you don't
look like a harsh person and so
one of the one of the dimensions one of
the cardinal personality dimensions
there's five of them you may know this
extroversion
which is a positive emotion and it's
associated with assertiveness and
enthusiasm yeah and trump is extroverted
definitely
negative emotion that's neuroticism and
that's the whole panoply of negative
emotions they all clump together and
people differ in their sensitivity to
them agreeableness
that's compassion and politeness on the
high end and more like bluntness and
competitiveness on the other end and
conscientiousness and openness which is
creativity you're obviously high in
openness you're entrepreneur you're a
writer you're interested in ideas you're
obviously creative but you strike me as
someone who's very high in agreeableness
compassion that's compassion and
politeness is that a reasonable
is that a reasonable i think that's
something that's sure i think that's
fairly spot on i would i couldn't have
been fine yeah i agree with you on that
certainly okay okay so i mean i mean
people are a little more complex than
that i do have other sides to myself i
do have a shadow side that is can be
very aggressive and very i'm very
competitive so it's i think on the
surface i have that kind of agreeable
personality for various reasons but yes
would you describe yourself as
compassionate
empathetic very much so yeah okay so
here's one
okay okay okay so that's i'm very
curious about that because
one of the disadvantages of being high
in agreeableness
is that
you're more likely to be a target for
disagreeable types
certainly and this is a really important
notion so
i was talking yesterday who was it with
i can't remember but we were talking
about oh yes it was andy no we were
talking about
the establishment of this you know
utopian community in the middle of
seattle the the
mayor described it
and said well maybe it'll be the summer
of love
which is extremely naive thing to think
especially because the summer of love
blew up and so
and you know that's sort of a
celebration of agreeable virtues and so
agreeable people are very generous and
kind and they're not backstabbing and
they're empathetic and they're
self-sacrificing and
and but there have been computer
simulations very sophisticated computer
simulations by evolutionary biologists
of what happens if you get agreeable
people together so imagine you have a
population of people and all of them are
agreeable and so they're cooperating
away it's all very kind and nice but if
you put one person in there who has
psychopathic traits yes he just takes
over everything yeah and so the
agreeable people always have the problem
of how do you handle free riders
cheaters and psychopaths and you know
you might be utopian and say well those
people just don't exist and they
shouldn't exist and we shouldn't
structure our societies that way but
that ain't going to cut it because
psychopaths are always three percent of
the population they vary between one and
five
and so if you're so so is it possible
i don't want to push this interpretation
beyond its reasonable limits but i'm i'm
wondering you're you're open and
creative and entrepreneurial and so
that's not going to suit you for
managerial or bureaucratic jobs you
don't have the temperament for that and
then you're agreeable and so is it
possible that you encountered more of
that bullying behavior or like a
disproportionate amount of that bullying
behavior and so forth in the jobs that
you had is that
i think that's very possible and yes and
i'm also very sensitive so i'm kind of
you know react a little bit more than
most other people might react but the
odd thing is is that the book came out
in 1998
and it has resonated with lots and lots
of readers i've sold millions of copies
of the book
and so there's some i think a lot of
people share the trait that i have oh
there's no doubt about it that that's
it's not uncommon what i'm talking about
at all
i mean the the great manipulators in the
world the three percent that you talk
about and i think that's about the right
number they don't need this kind of book
because they're born that way or they're
not born that way but they learned at
the age of three or four or five how to
begin to manipulate and their whole
personality was kind of formed over
these sort of tactics they don't need a
book like that what seems to happen
there we studied that you know so
if you take two-year-olds and you group
them
together two-year-olds by the way group
together are the most violent of human
beings oh definitely age-matched groups
okay so yes among two years
two-year-olds there's a proportion of
them who will spontaneously kick fight
hit bite and steal yeah they're almost
all males and it's about five percent of
the males now most of them this goes to
nature versus nurture say most of them
get socialized out of that by the time
they're four now they would be more
disagreeable boys so they're not
empathic and compassionate polite by
temperament but they can still be
socialized but a proportion of them
don't get socialized right and they tend
to be life-course anti-social types
yeah i think
melanie klein she looked at infants like
that of that age and she said that there
was something called the greedy baby
and the greedy baby was like sucking the
mother's breast so hard it could never
get enough milk it was just so greedy
for more and more and she saw that this
the child got older that kind of
greediness and that kind of selfish
behavior only got worse and worse and
worse and she would like try and see if
you could track that to someone who got
who became older it was a time and she
ended up thinking that there was maybe a
genetic component oh yeah well there is
a genetic component too because that
sort of proclivity runs in families but
and also there's a genetic underpinning
to variation in agreeableness now you
know if you have a tough kid like that
and you're very agreeable the kid can
run roughshod over you it's very
difficult for you to do the
socialization and so like one of the one
of the problems that women face with men
so men are reliably less agreeable than
women that's cross-culturally and it's
true it's even more true in egalitarian
societies and so women have to be
agreeable because i think primarily
because they have to take care of
infants and that's an extremely
self-sacrificing occupation especially
when they're under nine months
but with men they have to select men who
are agreeable enough to be generous and
kind and share but they have to be
disagreeable enough to keep the real
psychopaths and and the manipulators at
bay and so it's a chronic problem for
the human race okay so you're you're
doing all these jobs and you're seeing
the politicking and politicking and it's
not going well for you
you decide to analyze the behavior of
the people that are acting in these
underground oppressive ways and you're
definitely gonna see that if if you're
if you're being pushed around a lot
you know and so you decided to make that
an object of study
yeah um you know i wasn't it's not so
much that i was pushed around some of it
was also just observing how other people
were being treated i have this idea that
i talk about in the book that you know
people will always wear the the mask of
being agreeable and friendly even the
most psychotic boss will always know how
to be somewhat charming and present
themselves but you look at how they
treat other people when you're not
observing them behind closed doors and
that's when some of their ugly behavior
will come out they kind of hide it very
well from from from the public so a lot
of it was observing how other people
were mistreated and so when i worked in
hollywood
you know in some industries i have to
say some industries are a lot worse than
others so when you're working at that
factory job that you're mentioning
people will tend to be kind of united
around the single purpose there won't be
much politicking going on yeah in an
environment an environment where
hollywood so much of it is money
and ego etc the levels and the desire
for fame you know and that's going to
attract a disproportionate number so
it's the people that are are more likely
to be the way that you describe are high
in extroversion
especially assertiveness and they're low
in agreeableness that's kind of the
personality disorder axis high in
extroverted assertiveness and low in
agreeableness especially compassion and
then if you add unconscientiousness to
that you gotta you got someone who's
bordering on psychopathic
right and they could still be high in
openness they could still be creative
and intelligent but they'd be
manipulative as hell and callous
and
and and i would say that another thing i
was going to ask you is because you
worked in hollywood and that is a uh a
place that that invites people who want
to be
to make a display of themselves let's
say and there's some utility in that
right we want people to be actors we
want them to be enthusiastic and
entertaining yes but but it's so do you
is it possible that a lot of this you
saw
was a consequence of the form of
industry that you were involved in
especially in hollywood well definitely
but um after the book came out my first
book the 48 laws became hugely popular
in the hip-hop world among musicians
which is why i ended up doing a book
with 50 cent and i found out that the
music industry was even worse than
hollywood and then i was in washington
for a book tour
for the 48 laws and this woman came
running up to me who worked in voice of
americans she was saying you have no
idea how the
the 48 laws of power exactly describe
the environment i'm in and then i was in
a conference with people who were in um
non-profits in san diego and this phone
was saying boy you described the
non-profit work politically it is so so
perfect because it is so political it's
so much about ego
so it's horrible that's true of the
non-profit world you know well i mean
that might have to do with that moral
posturing eh
well i the way i look at it is you had a
place like the soviet union where
your degree of power wasn't based on any
kind of statistics it wasn't that you
performed better than others it wasn't
that your brand your economic branch was
was outperforming others and therefore
you were elevated to a higher position
it was pure politicking it was pure
manipulation how close could you get to
yeah
it's hierarchy maneuvering yeah so when
you have like a non-profit world where
it's not based on money or or or um you
know results it's more on it's you get
very political environments like that
where there's no kind of quantification
of what one is doing superior work than
others yeah you know i talked to um
um
woodridge wooldridge adrian woldridge
and he wrote some books on the history
of meritocracy they're very very
interesting he writes for the economist
and he so
you know that the idea of meritocracy is
under assault now i think the idea of
merit per se is under assault and what
wooldridge has done was look at how
societies were structured in the absence
of the meritocratic ethos and so that's
in the absence of a belief that there is
such a thing as productive competence
and he talked about nepotism which by
the way psychopaths practice nepotism
they're not only selfish they they do
differentially benefit their immediate
kin absolutely and hereditary
aristocracy so if you don't have
meritocracy and if your hierarchies
aren't predicated on competence you
don't get a utop a non-competitive
utopia
yeah exactly you get nepotism and and
this political infighting and that is
like it's no wonder that affected you
because that's that's absolutely toxic
it it's just sickening and it does
produce a situation where the worst
people
can
the worst people torture the people who
are competent for their competence
it's really ugly
yeah and and uh you know when i came out
of university i went to university of
wisconsin and i had you know my degree
in classics and literature et cetera you
know i wasn't expecting this i expected
that the harder you tried the more the
better your the work that you produced
the more you try to you know get results
that's what mattered right and then to
suddenly be blindsided this because
nobody in our culture in tells young
people that this is what the world is
going to be like and that's some sort of
a lot of where this book came out of i
wrote it when i was 38 39 so i was
already a bit older but your parents
don't prepare you for this schools don't
prepare you for this university
certainly doesn't prepare you for in
fact it leads you to believe the
opposite
and so you enter the work world and if
you're entering a place
more like what we're describing here not
like what you were describing some of
the jobs you had
you're blindsided you had no preparation
for it nothing prepared you for it and
you don't know how to react well you
know if if you're naive in that manner
two things and i was naive yeah one is
that you're much more likely to be
exploited that definitely happens the
other thing is you're much more likely
to be traumatized because
trauma sort of
occurs in proportion to how much
of your belief it it demolishes and so
if you have a
and too positive and too naive view of
the world and you especially if you
encounter someone malevolent they can
really do you in psychologically yeah
and they often will too because well
they have their their reasons and so
yeah
yeah i can remember um
i i had a job in journalism and i wrote
this article um about italy and i
thought it was a great article
and then the editor um brought me in for
lunch
and he was he was like having his second
or third martini and he started to tell
me that
robert you're never going to be a writer
you don't have the discipline for it
you're just too wild you you don't
communicate to the reader etc you need
to get out of this business it's not for
you
it was very painful and then looking
back in it i think he had set me up for
this i think that he was
had
kind of commissioned this article
knowing that it was going to have some
problems with it etc and he was
deliberately setting me up in this
situation so that he and i think a lot
of it came from nb
you know
envy and resentment man those are
corrosive it they're they're they're
soul and culture destroying emotions you
know when i worked with my clients
we talked a lot about resentment a lot
and i i had kind of an axiom which is
well if you're resentful
there's only one of two things going on
one is you're whiny and neurotic and
it's time to grow the hell up and take
some responsibility right so you've got
to ask yourself that and the second is
someone is taking advantage of you and
you have something to say or do that
you're not saying or doing and so we try
to sort out which of those it was and
then if it was that they had something
to say or do to stand up for themselves
for example then we'd just strategize
like mad so i had one client for example
i really liked her she was smart man
uh very very very competent honest
hard-working
conscientious diligent attractive lawyer
and uh she'd move firms and those firms
can be pretty cutthroat you know
they're full of prosecutors what do you
expect right right right and and
one guy when she went into the firm
basically
swiped her biggest client through a
series of manipulative actions right and
you know kind of lulled her into a false
sense of security sort of started to
cooperate with her and then shunted her
out and then when she started to
complain about it he started
distributing rumors that she had mental
health issues and
and oh it was all absolutely awful so we
spent about six months strategizing how
to deal with him
and so it was successful you know and i
love doing that sort of thing it was
such fun helping people who are yeah
yeah i do the same thing as well yeah
i'm sorry
so why do you think this was so popular
or you said the music industry was
particularly pathological at least this
is the reports you got so why do you
why do you think that
is do you have any theories about that
and then why do you think your books got
to be so popular among well rappers say
uh why do you think it the music
industry is the way it is or yeah i mean
i mean do you think there's something
specific about that industry that lends
itself yeah kind of yes and and i've had
a lot of um people give me the same kind
of feedback
there's a lot of money around right huge
amounts of money around
and um
and
people are
producers of music are very mute they
have a very exploitative kind of model
of business which is they
they seduce a first-time artist with a
with a lot of money but the contract is
and eventually they own all of the work
etc
so it was a very exploitive business
model particularly for african-american
musicians who were historically very
exploited and so
it's it's like hollywood where so much
of it is about pleasing people and
having the right demeanor so so 50 cent
i wrote the book with he said you know
he dealt crack on the streets of
southside queens you know he's was a
hustler at the age of nine he saw
everything but nothing prepared him for
the kind of machiavellian games that
music industry people would right
take a straightforward criminal over a
psychopathic manipulator any day
yeah yeah exactly well and you talked
about money like i'd rather deal with
someone greedy like honestly greedy than
someone manipulative underground
politicker right because at least with
the greed well you can negotiate with
someone like that you know what they
want they're kind of interdimensional
and you might have your moral qualms
about it but i'd still i think that's
partly why i'm an admirer of capitalism
it's like greed is not the worst of the
vices by any stretch of the imagination
no no i agree with you on that
and so you know why are my books popular
i think there's a it's a combination of
things first of all
i'm giving people something that's not
out there kind of a realism and i think
a lot of people are inwardly very tired
and very sick of all the kind of
coddling that goes on with readers and
in our culture where the people are
trying to you know perpetuate this myth
it's all about cooperation and getting
along and that business is kind of this
world where people are all on the same
page trying to create the best product
possible etc and they kind of have the
same kind of illusions that i had and so
the kind of the harshness of the book
that you that first kind of shocked you
sort of excites people it appeals to
their shadow side if you will you know
and that shadow side is very much
repressed in our culture and i think
artists and writers and people who
produce work that kind of
vents some of that shadow some of those
darker emotions that people have it has
a very attracting pull on them so i
think that's part of the reason because
there's a kind of a notoriety around the
book and people almost feel like it's
something naughty when they have it and
so i think that's part of the appeal of
it
so i have a friend he's a really good
friend of mine and i've known him since
i was in college and he's a tough guy i
mean he grew up in a
under rather poverty-stricken
circumstances in northern alberta really
on a frontier piece of land like it had
only been
broken 50 years before by his father who
was a longshoreman and the next military
guy good guy his father but this guy
grew up and he's tough he worked in lead
smelters and he wandered around western
canada he was my roommate when i went to
college and is still a good friend of
mine and he ended up working with like
delinquents he went into social work
oddly enough and
and he ended up working with some of the
worst delinquents in in canada and he's
a really good guy and he likes to help
people
get better
but he isn't naive at all and then part
of the reason that he was good at
working with the delinquents was because
there were no tricks they could get up
to that he couldn't see right through
and that was partly because he had a
real integrated shadow i mean i'll give
you an example of him
so one day
i was living in this town called grand
prairie and it was at the height of the
oil boom and so it was a rough town and
there were lots of rough bars and lots
of young men in there with plenty of
money and plenty they come in for you
know three days after being out minus 40
weather working on the oil rigs and they
were ready to party man we had a party
one night in this kind of frat house
that i went to college in and about oh
way too many people showed up and some
of them were real troublemakers and one
we had a table that was pretty full of
beer bottles and vodka wattles and so
forth and one guy just went over like
tore the leg off and knocked the table
over and then a bunch of us got together
and chased them all out and
this friend of mine he said oh they'll
be back and so he went upstairs and he
put on some steel-toed cowboy boots it
was just like a bloody western he came
marching down the stairs and just as he
entered the living room there was a big
knock on the front door it was these
hooligans coming back to cause grief and
he
he just didn't break stride he opened
the door he pulled open the door and
there was a guy standing there ready to
fight and he kicked him underneath the
chin with his steel tool cowboy boot
knocked him right over the
the front porch and there you know and
the battle was on but that was exactly
what he was like you know
and he had his shadow was integrated you
could he's a great roommate he
he reciprocated everything i always knew
if i bought groceries one week he'd buy
it the next like he was a straight
shooter you could trust him but he was
not naive man and
that made him able to deal with
delinquents and to help them so that's
part of that integration of that shadow
yeah um i go very deeply into the shadow
in in a chapter in my last book the laws
of human nature
and i try and talk about how one
integrates the shadow because it's not
it's not an easy answer for that you
know people are kind of perplexed well i
have this dark side and i explain a lot
of where it comes from and how a lot of
your aggressive impulses like the room
of two-year-olds that you were talking
about
you have that as well i'm talking to the
people that have
my readers you have that aggressiveness
when you were young and it got
socialized out of you and then it kind
of got repressed and it's like a lost
self that lives inside of you and is
screaming to come out how do you
integrate it and so the main thing is
you have to be aware that you have this
shadow side you have you can't run away
from it you have to acknowledge that it
exists you almost have to raise it a
good parent too does everything he or
she can not to repress that like what
you want to do with children is you want
to
like you want them to be forceful you
want them to have some power
you want them to integrate that that
capacity for aggression into well let's
say lucid conversation you want them to
be able to stand up for themselves in
family discussions if you just punish
them for being
aggressive let's say for talking back or
something like that you don't guide that
into more sophisticated development you
see this in schools too now you know
when my kids went to school this was so
dumb i we had a rule in our house which
was
you don't have to follow stupid rules
that's a good rule but if you get caught
you have to put up with consequences but
right so one rule was
the school had not only could you not
throw snowballs
you couldn't make them
and so they were trying to yeah exactly
you should shake your head that's for
sure it's like because their answer and
this was all politically correct
nonsense you know non-competitive games
we're only going to play non-competitive
games it's like first of all you know i
studied piaget
yeah a hockey game is not competitive
exactly because in a hockey game well
everybody no one brings a basketball
everybody plays hockey so that's
cooperation and then on the team you
have to cooperate and like if you're the
star but you never pass you're just a
dumb son of a [ __ ] you're not the star
and so there's tremendous amount of
cooperation in all those competitive
games they're integrated and this idea
that you know make children better by
not allowing them to be competitive it's
so
it's disgusting it is it's that well
that's the freudian devouring mother
right that's oh well everyone's safe and
no one's gonna ever hurt anyone and
that's kind of where a lot of young
people are you know they enter the world
where they've been called where they
think that there are no winners that
everyone is you know it's just win-win
situations and that's where they get
really shocked by the realities of the
world so all this coddling and this idea
that
there doesn't have to be a winner we
don't have to get prizes for first place
everybody should get a prize you know
all you're doing is setting your
children up for
for massive uh
you know
shocks when they enter the world and
they see that it's not like that yeah
and then they get disillusioned and
depressed you know or traumatized but i
mean when my my son's hockey team
in his school they won the the city
championship which was a big deal you
know and the school was pretty happy
about that to to his credit so was the
coach but the principal who was this
authoritarian empath she was an awful
person i thought authoritarian
empathy yeah well yeah she used more
virtue as a club
yeah well there's plenty of those people
around yeah she said well really today
we're all winners
and the and the coach had the yeah
exactly no it is sickening because it's
and you know my son was just appalled by
but the coach had enough guts he said no
no the hockey team won and it's not like
the kids in the school were jealous some
of them were obviously but most of them
were really happy like you are when your
sports team wins that yeah you know and
most people are generous enough so that
they're able to celebrate someone else's
victory without and that's the same i
saw this with birthday parties i just
bloody well hated this it's like well
every child gets a gift bag it's like no
you know they have their damn birthday
every child doesn't need a damn gift bag
and it's this is this same this same
naive trickly
and it's authoritarian too because it
imposes this kind of view of the world
it's like no it's this kid's data be
special that's why we're celebrating
this kid the rest of them if they can't
take that it's like
there's something wrong with the way
that they've been
treated and it tends to
well a lot of my books i've tried to
remove the kind of taboo or the negative
associations we have with the word like
power or with the word ambition you know
i try and say ambition is a good thing
it means that you have you you believe
in yourself you you have some self love
and you believe you're worth something
and you want to go out and achieve and
create something worthwhile for other
people so ambition is a is a positive
thing but so many people are just kind
of embarrassed about being human being
embarrassed about our primate nature
embarrassed about our own aggressive
impulses this is partly why boys are
failing in our schools now at a
disproportionate rate you know the
and i see this there's an assault of the
sort that you're describing on the
better part of striving masculinity and
you know i had a friend who killed
himself because he identified his
ambition with
you know the the
patriarchal force that's devouring the
environment let's say and that's a con
that's you know
the cause of of historical horror and
you might say well no one takes that on
to themselves to that degree and that's
well you can say that but that you just
don't know what the hell you're talking
about people take that on to themselves
all the time and then they they start to
identify the best part of them that
strives forward with the destructive
impulses of humanity and they're so
ashamed because they can't do anything
good then but in principle
yeah you know he tried to be as
inoffensive and harmless in every
possible way as he possibly could and it
just sucked all the life out of what you
end up turning that aggressive energy on
yourself is what ends up happening and
that's maybe leads to suicide the
ultimate kind of self-aggression
i know that i personally have as i said
i definitely have a shadow side i'm very
aggressive and extremely competitive and
i have a lot of anger
so a lot of that those experiences in my
youth made me very angry
but the way i kind of integrated my show
i'm not saying this is a model but the
way i integrated it was through my books
so i kind of that anger kind of seeps
through the material that i write and i
find i can only write when i have that
kind of anger but i don't rant i don't
yell and kind of put people down i kind
of channel it into something productive
and something creative and so yeah i
definitely do that when i'm lecturing
you know and people have commented you
know some of the people who've
criticized me that i'm an angry person
and which isn't true
but it's definitely that anger that
capacity for anger definitely is
something that gives you force and it
can push and anger definitely so
psychophysiologically so imagine that
this is obviously a thought experiment
but imagine you're chasing a cat with a
broom
well the cat's gonna run from the broom
but if you corner the cat with the broom
it will attack you even though it's just
a cat well the reason for that is that
fear will facilitate either freezing or
escape right but sometimes fear isn't
the right response and anger will
suppress fear and so one of the tools
that we have at our disposal
psychologically is anger as an
antidote to the terror that would
otherwise freeze you and you can
integrate that you know that's
you know if you if you have some
justifiable moral outrage let's say
something really annoys you
or
or
or
i shouldn't say that deeply violates
your sense of moral propriety i don't
mean
trivial things
then the fact of that forceful response
can motivate you to do things well
for lecture but certainly to write
but it takes a lot of energy to write
man you need all those sources of energy
if you're going to be able to do it
just even to turn it on yourself to
discipline yourself you know it's like i
had to grab myself by the scruff of the
neck when i was a young guy to sit down
sit down god damn it and write
you know and and there's a force that's
necessary to especially if you're open
because you're all over the place if
you're creative to
get yourself to sit down and focus
yes that's right yeah
and um
you know some of that
anger you know i think young talks about
this is that that dark side contains a
lot of energy it contains a lot of power
those two-year-olds are kicking and
screaming that's all this kind of force
behind it
and when you sort of are ashamed of it
and you push that down you're kind of
getting rid of an incredible well of
energy that you can use for your
creativity for your work etc you can
take that energy like you say and create
discipline out of it
do something creative out of it
support some cause that you really
believe in
you know so that shadow side
when you when you deny it only negative
things will happen and and it is
extremely important for people to first
recognize it in themselves you know and
it's it's very hard for a lot of people
to do that
well i found like i said earlier that
one of the best ways in there is
resentment
you watch yourself like well because if
you're if you're resentful
you know you're feeling like you're
being victimized and mistreated it's
like okay well you might maybe you are
okay and you think there's no anger in
that resentment you're not looking hard
enough if you watch your fantasies for
example if you're resentful and you
watch the fantasies that flip through
your imagination like you might not want
to attend to them because they can be so
brutal right but but that the fat
because if someone is is oppressing you
genuinely and you're not standing up for
yourself then there'll be these
compensatory fantasies yeah so one day
i'll tell you a story about that so one
day i was i'd been renovating my house
and it took a long time and
the neighbors this house was a complete
derelict and it was a semi-detached like
really a derelict it hadn't been touched
since like 1927 had gas fittings in the
upper floor needed to be completely
gutted and so we got it and my daughter
got sick at exactly the same time really
sick and so it was it was stressful and
difficult and the neighbors just they
called the city on us they they did
everything they could to make it
difficult even though they were attached
to us and wanted to sell their house so
we probably added like 25 000 to the
value of their house because it was no
longer attached to a derelict
and then just as we were finishing
my sister and her husband came to visit
and
i was making tea for them and i closed
the cupboard so it clicked
and the neighbors banged on the wall
and then that night i couldn't sleep and
i had this
i would really be pushed to my limit by
these people and i had these visions in
my mind of burning the damn place down
and i thought oh man if you're starting
to think about burning the place down
you sh
you should probably go say something so
i took put on my park and i went outside
about
six in the morning and i just waited for
them to come out they never did but i
went knocked over on the door and i said
i was making tea for my sister last
night
and i closed the cupboard you didn't
happen to bang on the wall
because you heard my cupboard closing
did you
and they said yeah and i said okay look
if you bug me anymore
i'm going to cause you so much trouble
you cannot possibly imagine it yeah and
i meant it it was like because i knew
what was brewing in the back of my mind
i said because i was done it was like
you want a war you have no idea what
you're getting into and so they backed
into the kitchen and like two hours
later they came over and said oh you
know we're sorry and we won't do it
again but like i
what we did was the mistake you talk
about we backtrack continually trying to
please them you know and every time they
complained we did what they wanted
because we assumed we were dealing with
reasonable people but we weren't and
yeah the only way to stop them was
with a show of force it was like right
you want to be malevolent
you want to play that game it's like
okay no problem
but
you know when things went more smoothly
after that and and that's a good example
of well paying attention to those
fantasies because i thought i better
like deal with this straightforwardly
otherwise i'm likely to do something
stupid right that's the other thing
you've got to watch if that builds up
inside you
exactly
yeah and a lot of times i look at people
in in the public eye who get caught
doing something really stupid like you
say
and their first thing will be well that
wasn't me that did it i don't know what
came over me that's not that's not who i
am but that is exactly who you are that
is the person who has been carrying this
resentment and this kind of inner anger
but not acting upon then suddenly they
do something really stupid like having
an affair with the 21 year old or or you
know they're just caught doing something
yeah so i i i watch people with their
their children a lot hey yeah and so
when my son was a pretty assertive kid
and tough like he had a real will
and uh
you know when he was nine months old and
started to crawl around i taught him
what no meant and no what no means is
stop doing that or something you don't
like will happen to you that's what no
means right and so when he was nine
months he was starting to take books off
shelves and get into the plants and so
on and because he was starting to crawl
around and so to teach him what no man i
just grabbed his leg
when he wasn't doing something that he i
didn't want him to do and
you know he would squawk and [ __ ] and
complain and i'd say no no no and i just
hold him until he gave up and sometimes
he would cry and the reason he was
crying is because he was frustrated and
angry that i was mucking about with him
it's like fair enough he wanted to go
explore and you know fair enough kid you
want to explore but you can't
tear out the plant and get dirt all over
the rug and you can't go into the
electrical cords you know like no right
and no and so i
i had done a lot of behavioral training
by that time and by the time i did that
for say six or seven days and soon as if
i just said no he would just stop and
sometimes he would cry and then the week
later if i said no he'd just stop so it
took like two weeks say and then then i
knew that if i said no he would stop and
so then i could let him explore i could
give him a lot of freedom and then i'd
have people come over to my house with
their two-year-old or three-year-old and
because they had never taught the child
what no meant
they never gave because they didn't want
to impose on their freedom let's say
they couldn't give the child any freedom
at all they had to wander around behind
them all the time because they never
knew what the child was going to get
into
right so then you start to hate your
child right because instead of having a
bit of free time and just being able to
say no to this kid while he's playing
around on his own and giving him some
freedom
you're just non-stop
monitoring this child and you're mad
because you don't have a life and we had
another couple come over
and they had two kids that were like
four and five and they were just
horrible we sat down to eat we wanted to
have a conversation and
we put a basket of bread out and the
kids just grabbed the bread and they ate
all the centers out of the bread and the
parents were all embarrassed about it
and but they didn't do anything to stop
it and you know in their minds they
thought well aren't we permissive and
nice and we never say no to our children
but they didn't notice that they
actually hated their children because
how could you go to someone's house and
you want to have a conversation you just
met them and your children embarrass you
to death and you think you're not going
to get resentful about that
right and you think you're not going to
take and so here's how people would take
it out on their kids so imagine that
happens
now you go home and you're pissed right
off but you're not going to let yourself
know that because you're such a nice
person then your child goes off and
draws a picture maybe they put a lot of
work into it eh then they come running
up to show you
and that's a real good time to give them
a pat on the head and say look isn't
that great but you're pissed off because
you were embarrassed and so you look at
it and you think
uh
and that's all you have to do it's like
that's not really worthy of my attention
you don't have to say anything mean you
just have to not attend in this manner
and then you got your revenge
and you think you won't do that man you
know nothing about yourself and you know
you read in the paper sometimes these
mothers or fathers they do something
brutal to a child
and i know what that i know how that
happens it's like
no disciplinary strategies in the house
yeah the kid is driving the mother or
father crazy
you know and then maybe the mother or
father they're hungover one day and
maybe they just broke up with their
boyfriend or girlfriend maybe they got
you know hail it from their boss who's a
tyrant and they haven't stood up to them
and the kid does the wrong thing at
exactly the wrong time and maybe he's
actually pretty good at that by then
and it's like out comes satan himself
and all hell breaks loose it's like i
wouldn't do that it's like yeah there's
almost nothing you wouldn't do you just
don't know yourself very well
yeah
yeah well the ability the ability to set
limits and to say no and to tell people
that you know it's not right for you to
bang on my house at this hour and etc
etc etc
that takes a little bit of toughness on
your part you have to be kind of willing
to put yourself on the line maybe that
person will get angry and hit you or
something or maybe the war will escalate
but you have to be willing to take that
risk because if you don't then then you
set no limits and who knows what they'll
end up doing but a lot of this
permissiveness
is people are just basically afraid
they're afraid of any kind of
confrontation yeah they're afraid of any
kind of conflict and through conflict
and confrontation is how you actually
grow it's actually how you develop as a
person yeah so here's a cool stat this
is really interesting man so there's
been some great work on
what predicts what behavioral markers
predict divorce in couples counseling
really solid work okay so here's one
predictor if
when the couple is talking in front of a
therapist and one of them or the other
or both roll their eyes there's like a
95 chance they're going to be divorced
within six months and that's contempt
they've got so they've become so dis
connected because they don't communicate
because the resentment has built up that
they now have contempt for each other
but here's here's another cool fact from
that research
so
if you have people track the number of
positive and negative interactions with
their partner
you can calculate ratios and then you
can see what the ratio is that
that lends itself to the successful
maintenance of a relationship
and so you might think well the more
positive interactions the better
and that's kind of true so if it falls
below five positive to one negative the
relationship is in danger but if it
rises you have five to one
and you can kind of see that because you
know
negative events are more memorable and
and and more powerful than positive ones
and so you know that if you read youtube
comments you know yeah but if it rises
above 11 to 1
the relationship is also in danger and
you can imagine that what you want in a
relationship is well you want support
and love and you want most of your
interactions to be positive but you want
your partner to slap you now and then
when you're being stupid
right because and then if they don't out
comes your inner tyrant right you're
just going to dominate them if they
don't push back and so if you have any
sense too if you have a partner you want
to encourage them to
put limits on you you know especially if
they're a little more timid than you
temperamentally it's like you don't want
to run roughshod over them because they
know some things you don't
right it's so cool that it's above 11 to
1 so that means too much positivity is
also
is the death knoll for a relationship
and you know you want someone with some
spark right it's like well what if i
push you a little bit even teasing
you want the push
per person to be able to push back a bit
and you have to be able to accept it as
well because some people probably in
those situations can't stand any kind of
criticism
they're so fragile that if the other
person pushes back it kind of escalates
into a battle
so so real strength comes from the
ability in a relationship or any kind of
really intimate or otherwise is the
ability to take that kind of criticism
to actually welcome it when people set
limits for you and tell you that this
kind of behavior is wrong and then you
can evaluate and assess yourself
yeah unless you want to repeat it
stupidly forever right i mean that
that's the alternative in a relationship
is i don't like conflict i've been in
plenty of conflicts like plenty way more
than
is reasonable but i don't like them like
i
i i
well i meet people now and then i went
to talk to douglas murray in in new york
city about a week ago and we were
talking about conflict and he said you
know
he he doesn't mind a fight and i've met
lots of people like that that you know
they like that combativeness and i don't
really but
what i really hate is
deferred conflict that escalates it's
like it's better to get it over with now
and you're a fool if you think that
running away from it is gonna you know
like if if someone cuts you off in
traffic and they're obviously really
angry it's probably better just to get
the hell out of there because you're
never gonna see that person again you
know and you don't want a situation like
that to escalate because
they might have a gun or whatever well
yeah you don't just don't know what's up
with them they're really strangers
but you know if you're dealing with
someone day in and day out and they're
pushing on the top of your head to stop
you from growing which i think lucy used
to do to line us in the peanuts cartoons
yeah they had a dark side those cartoons
man they they called them they sure did
yeah yeah they would be canceled now
probably
yeah they couldn't do this now i don't
think yeah i think that's right yeah
cause a lot of schultz's characters lucy
was actually not a likeable character at
all right and she she was really
oppressive to linus who was a good
character
yeah yeah
yeah and a good humor always has an edge
but yeah that that you don't get rid of
your
the negative part of yourself especially
that aggressive part by pretending it
doesn't exist that that quite the
contrary you know that just doesn't work
at all
right
yeah look i'm sorry you're gonna say
something i was just gonna ask you about
your name yeah i wanted to ask you about
working with 50 cent and the rappers and
i wanted to ask you about your new book
too so let's start with so how did this
partnership with 50 cent come about
well um the book was very popular with
rappers um as i said because of the
nature of the music industry
and um he reached out to me he wanted to
meet me because the 48 laws of power was
sort of his bible as he expressed it
so i met him in new york
kind of in the back room of the
steakhouse and sort of like a something
straight out of the godfather i was kind
of the one white guy amongst his whole
group there i was a little bit
intimidated to be honest i didn't know
what to expect because he has his
reputation
ended up he was really nice really
interesting actually very kind of sweet
guy not what you expect
and we i just finished writing my book
on warfare and strategy which is kind of
my version of sun tzu's art of war how
to strategize and conflicts sort of like
what you're talking about
and he has a very strategic mind and he
got we got very we kind of had a really
nice connection
and i thought you know so much in our
culture is creating these stupid kind of
divisions and walls like you're in
academia you only write academic books
you're a popular person you only write
popular books you know you come from
this community you come from that
community and they should never
communicate
and i thought it would be very
interesting to write a book
coming from two opposite
backgrounds you know me middle class
jewish boy from los angeles and him from
southside queens
something interesting could happen from
a collaboration there's not enough of
that in our culture i believe because
even though our circumstances were very
different our minds were very similar we
were thinking on a similar plane that
kind of transcended these sort of
superficial differences
so i spent time with him
and i was trying to figure out what is
the essence of his power what makes him
such a compelling figure and made him
not one of those people in southside
queens who ended up kind of spiraling
downward to ending up in prison what
saved him and i determined that the
quality he had was this kind of
fearlessness
and it isn't the kind of fearlessness
where you go beating people up or
something it's kind of an inner strength
he had been shot when he was like 20
years old like nine bullets right there
through a car window
um kind of lo one of them both lodged in
his mouth
and he survived miraculously
and it gave him this kind of calmness
like i have nothing to fear i almost
died bring it on i don't really care
and so
i observed him in meetings i observed
that kind of calmness and how he could
take over a meeting not by being super
aggressive but just by having this kind
of dominant persona
and i thought there's tremendous power
in this fearlessness not being afraid to
be different not being afraid to have
conflict and confrontation not being
afraid of of actually
of death itself not being afraid of the
reality of your situation on and on so
the book that we formed together was
kind of a meditation on ten forms of
fearlessness and i found
you know i thought that i was a
relatively fearless person which in some
ways i am i seem agreeable but i'm
actually in some ways a little bit bold
and adventurous
and but compared to him i realized no
i'm actually riddled with fears and just
being around him and kind of writing the
book helped me a lot in my you know kind
of overcome some of my own limits and
some of my own fears so that's where
that looks yeah it's nice to have a
model like that really close by right to
contrast yourself with
yeah you can learn a lot from so do you
think you think that fearlessness that
you saw in him you think part of that
was a consequence of that brush with
death how much of that do you think was
temperamental to
in him well well there's there's a
there's a kind of a reckless
fearlessness that a lot of people from
the hood have which doesn't really serve
them very well and it gets them in a lot
of trouble right he has a very kind of
strategic in under control
fearless hey i got something cool to
tell you about that so i was talking to
um
david buss
yes
i believe it and he's an evolutionary
psychologist a good one
we're talking about this uh
machiavellian personality triad the dark
triad the del pollo's ubc yeah okay so
here's something really interesting
um it's the bad boy paradox they call it
that young naive women are attracted to
those machiavellian types
but when they get older and more
experienced they start to be able to see
through that the reason they're
attracted to it as far as i can tell and
i talked about this with bus to see if i
was way off on the wrong track is that
those reckless fearless people
mimic real fearless competence
and young women aren't good at
distinguishing between the two and so
they get sucked in by the sort of
psychopathic recklessness because they
think it's fearless competence
and then of course the guys who are
doing that they'll they'll prey on that
because they're trying to aim competence
but what the women are really after in
their heart of hearts they might be out
for an adventure too because there's
that element of it but they want that
fearlessness that
does go along with true generosity and
competence and also the ability to keep
you know real darkness away
so
well a lot of those people who display
that kind of uh which you call mimicking
fearlessness
it's that's the yeah they're actually
hiding the opposite they're actually
very very riddled with insecurities
they're not you know and they're they're
they kind of
create this sort of bravado in this
false front and they go to an extreme to
kind of project this machismo when in
fact they're riddled with insecurities
and that's their way of dealing with it
but someone like 50 cent he was very
very comfortable with himself he knows
who he is he knows where he came from
his mother was a hustler on the streets
so he knew the limits of the game and i
don't know i think there is maybe a
slight genetic component to it i can't
really put my finger on why he was able
to have this kind of self-control where
other people do yeah well that that
dimension neuroticism you know if you're
in a rough environment and you're low in
neuroticism that's pretty damn helpful
because imagine that what neuroticism is
unit of psychophysiological
uh upset caused per unit of stress
yeah and some or unit of danger and some
people
overreact and some people underreact
sometimes the overreaction saves your
life
sometimes the under reaction gets you
killed so it's not like there's a clear
answer so there's variability there some
people are much more calm not volatile
they don't withdraw temperamentally
that's a more masculine temperament by
the way yeah i agree but if you if
you're raised in a really rough
environment and you happen to be
emotionally stable that's the opposite
of neurotic let's say then
you're just not going to be as affected
by it and that can be a real blessing
so and then i'm also interested in that
you know you said that you channeled a
lot of your shadow let's say into
creativity did you see the same thing
happening with 50 cent
oh my god his music is incredibly
aggressive and that's and then
and
to the extent that's kind of violent and
i must admit it really appeals to me
so um when i was why why why that's cool
because it's so interesting that so many
rap fans
are young white guys i know i know yeah
yeah but that's that's really
psychologically interesting right
because if if they've been coddled and
their ambition has been squelched and
everything about them that's aggressive
has been shamed out of existence it's
that's part of that attraction of that
dark fantasy right and then they see
that aggression manifesting itself and
in a creative form in rap it's not
surprising that they're going to try to
imitate that it's part of that a bit
that desire to bring that shadow out of
the shadows and into the light
well i i wasn't really um
i was a little bit different in that um
i kind of understand you know my own
anger i wasn't so much coddled but but
what i really enjoyed about the his
music is it just seemed very real
and
it kind of the the beat kind of catches
you up in a primal sense
and kind of the aggressiveness just
seems very direct and very refreshing
by the way and you could tell
you know i say in in my book mastery
that by a person's style by how they
write a book by the by how they put
language together or the music they
create reveals something very very deep
about their character about who they are
and so a lot of rap kind of comes across
as sort of faults like someone is trying
really hard to have that kind of thug
persona and it's not real
but it really smelled authentic with him
and the fact that he'd been shot nearly
died you know just kind of added to that
aura but there was something very real
about it very authentic in a culture
where so much isn't real i think that
was the deep deep appeal in a primal
sense of 50s music and when i was
writing the war book i was trying to get
myself in a martial mood to write it i
would actually listen to his music to
kind of put me in the mood to write some
of the chapters
that invade that in beethoven
what do you like from what what beta do
you like what what pumped you up well
when i was a kid one of the first albums
i was first kind of raised on classical
music then i got into jazz and rock and
everything but i got a collection of his
nine symphonies
and god there's there's a kind of a an
aggression in violence like to the fifth
symphony in the ninth symphony it's just
kind of you know like they used to talk
with orange
there's something so overwhelmingly
powerful about it right it just you just
section in the ninth is like that it's
showed to joy yeah and so isn't that so
interesting that the ode to joy has that
primal aggressive force and it
it makes joy it makes joys you know in
in the naive sense it's well you're
happy it's like no this joy is that
integrated terrible power that you
definitely hear in uh superb music
yeah
yeah
and so when it when that when that coral
bit kicks in it's just overwhelming it's
like a blow and
makes you tingle it's it's so exciting
and i've heard it maybe a thousand times
since then it still affects me the same
way and now
when i'm driving somewhere and i have to
get myself in the mood i'll still put
the night symphony on and some of the
other ones yeah it's like it's like
encountering the terrible force of good
you know you think about moses in the
burning bush it's or or jacob wrestling
with god it's like well why is it a
burning bush why is it terrifying why do
you wrestle with god why do you get hurt
it's like well because
good in its full force has this
unbelievable what has this integration
of power
and it's no wonder it terrifies people
because it just burns everything away in
comparison
right right
yeah i mean um a lot of the the new book
that i'm writing about which is the
sublime is as i'm talking about
it's a combination of two emotions
of of both kind of pain and pleasure of
excitement and fear at the same time
um so you're confronting something that
kind of
intimidates you but is so awesome that
you can you know you're just overwhelmed
and the confluence of two emotions
opposing emotions at the same time is
very very powerful for a human being
yeah i've just written a book that i'm
going to publish next year that's called
an abc of childhood tragedy and it's a
combination of dark humor and beauty
it's the same we're trying to we're
experimenting with exactly the same
thing those that paradoxical
juxtaposition of dark and light emotions
there is something sublime about that
that's and something awe-inspiring about
that
it's i guess it's it's part of bringing
what's dark into the light or subsuming
it under the light maybe so why did you
get why the sublime what are you
pursuing there and well what's the
reason
um
you know the the ultimate in sublime is
to me so the way i look at it is being a
human being and being socialized is a
kind of a world there's a limit a circle
that we have to live inside certain
codes and conventions that we have to
abide by and we all do that and the
codes and conventions for fifth century
bc china are not the same as what we
have now but there's still that limit
and what humans are attracted to what
lies beyond that limit it's just part of
our nature it's the first part of it
when we explore beyond the social limits
and codes and things we're supposed to
do in ways we're supposed to act it's
deeply exciting and thrilling there's
also that element of fear involved right
see i think that's a better that's a
better what would you call it
formulation than nietzsche's idea of
will to power is the desire to exist on
that sublime edge and that is the the
the border between order and chaos that
you're describing right you want and
the the thing and that is the source of
meaning itself i mean that's why i think
music is so powerful is because it plays
with predictable forms but continually
adds that level of unpredictability
beautiful you know how in any kind of
music
the simplest music someone who's good at
it country music you know there'll be a
key shift or a twang on the string or
something or something discordant yes
exactly and and then and integrated
within sort of a higher uh what a higher
unity and it's deeply meaningful it puts
you on that edge of the sublime
and and we are we do find the meaning
that helps sustain us in life exactly at
that place that's that's something more
deeply real than anything else
well so and and so the ultimate thing
beyond that limit is is death itself and
the word sublime means up to the
threshold of a door or sublime and lemon
being the limit right like so
and so
um i
i've been meaning to write this book for
15 years and i got distracted but then
about three years ago i nearly died
myself i had a stroke
and i came you know just an inch away
from dying myself i was driving my car
and so some of the experience the
near-death experience and what it kind
of taught me and how it sort of remained
with me three years later and how i kind
of feel it in my bones and how it's
altered how i look at the world and
everything around me
is to me the kind of the ultimate
sublime experience so now
unfortunately i'm able to write about
this in a way that's actually very
personal and experiential instead of
just purely intellectual
and unfortunately because of the price
you had to pay for it yeah the prices i
can't take a walk i can't do the swim i
can't do the things that i used to love
so
you know i'm kind of i can i can you
know i'm functional i can walk around
the house but i can't take a hike and i
can't do my long distance swimming or my
mountain biking or anything like that so
i paid a price but i'm alive
yeah well
and it was so interesting that that was
it was in the aftermath of that
devastating experience that you decided
to turn
particularly to the sublime
yeah
well it's because i've been wanting to
write the book for a long time and i
knew that it has to do a little bit with
the feeling of death
you know um
and what kind of understand that so what
why the why make that is i'm not
disputing it i don't i just don't
understand like
i mean you talked also about 50 cents
brush with death but why does the
sublime in your estimation why is it
tangled up with it with the idea of
death
well because there's there's a limb that
limit and experiencing the limit gives
you that sense of
excitement and fear at the same time
well death is the ultimate limit
and to have gone up to that door and
glimpsed to the other side and literally
felt it in your bones and literally feel
your bones melting away as you kind of
go into a coma
you know is like i went up to that door
i actually appeared inside of it now
other people have had much stronger
near-death experiences mine was more of
the milder sort but still i appeared as
far as as far as near-death experiences
going relatively minor well you know my
coma my coma lasted an hour or something
some people get up there that's nothing
man experts
for like three years
well okay all right
um
i could have had a you know a more
intense near-death experience but it was
pretty intense yeah it was sufficient
it is
but so
the sense of life is almost too much
it's overpowering and it's immediacy and
we humans try and kind of dull the
the the razor edge so much that we can
live but if you think about you know
your mortality in a day-to-day basis and
if you try and actually experience the
immediacy of life and how
dangerous it actually is and how it's
fraught with all of these
these you know these these things that
you don't want to confront
is is very very very powerful and
i'm sorry siri just keeps hearing me i'm
so
so annoying so um
you know
it creates
so when you have that it's it's like the
ultimate
it's a mix of you know they they call in
french the orgasm
liberty ball
right
right so an orgasm is almost like a
little death
you know
so that sense of it's almost too much
it's almost like death itself like
something so pleasurable can actually
kind of morph into something a little
bit frightening as well something a
little bit like you're like you're
exploring something that you're not
supposed to do now you see that in the
ease in which laughter and tears can be
interchanged right you see that with
children they can switch from laughter
to tears in no time and you know you can
laugh so hard that you cry and it's
often too when you're crying about
something sorrowful that someone can say
something funny and it'll switch to
laughter that's all the way down at the
level of instinct right where these
right it's so interesting to see the
opposites touch at that level
yeah
so so the reason why i'm doing the
elusivian mysteries just to bring that
back
is i have a chapter on pagan religions
on what i call the pagan sublime
and i'm trying to cr tell the reader
that
we don't have a right conception of
ancient religions they're actually very
different from what we think we have
these kind of cliched notions of kind of
mischievous gods cavorting in clouds
doing all kinds of naughty things that
are very human
and just kind of almost a silliness to
it like whoa we're so beyond that but
actually pagan religions were extremely
serious and they were based on creating
go away siri and they were
and they were based
on um creating very powerful emotional
responses in people and that was what
primal religion was about or ancient
religion was about it wasn't based on
texts on dogma on the written word so
the yellowstone mysteries because there
are mysteries because nobody ever wrote
about it there's no text there's nothing
written that we can go to yes there's
the hymn to demeter that kind of maybe
describes a little bit of what it's
based on but we don't know really what
happened because nothing was ever
written down it was simply about
creating this overwhelming emotional
reaction in which you took the the
initiates to the edge of death you made
them experience death in life
which is the story of demeter and
persephone you were like making them
feel as if they had gone into the
underworld itself and that created a
whole new relationship to life but i
wanted this idea that religion isn't
this kind of milk toasty thing that
people think about nowadays it was
initially extremely powerful reaction to
human vulnerability to our weakness in
this immense cosmos with all of these
very powerful forces and the religious
rituals were to actually mirror that and
give you a kind of complicatory sense
that you could control it you could
contain it within these kind of powerful
experiences so it's really interesting
to me that you know you've you've come
through your analysis of the darkness
and then a consequence of that was to be
motivated to pursue the sublime you know
it's it in the the little stamp that i'm
using for these kids book which i'm
doing with this illustrator named juliet
foger who's a real genius in my
estimation
we made a stamp and the motto on the
stamp is
through the darkness into the light
and wow you know and there's this old
idea
that if you look into the darkness
enough you'll find something that
compensates for it right and that
emerges out of the darkness that's
greater and more powerful than the
darkness and that part part of the
looking into the dark side of you
yourself as you find the power that
enables you to deal with mortality and
there is something sublime about that
it's so cool that you know all your work
investigating and trying to integrate
the shadow has led you to this
to this what what what that your
intuition has been gripped by the idea
of the sublime
yeah necessarily where you think you'd
end up
well yeah a lot of the um
impetus for the book is another little
bit of anger as well because i always
have to have some anger in order to feel
the you know the impulse to write and
just discipline myself and
my anger now is about how
people's worlds have become so tight and
so banal and so limited where they're
just kind of disappearing into their
phones
and their world is is just sort of
programmed for them by
by facebook or social media and they're
sort of told what they're supposed to
think and they're kind of programmed and
at the same time
you know what science is discovering
about the universe and about where we
live and about who we are is just so
insanely mind-blowing it's just
absolutely almost inca it's sublime in
my opinion and yet so many people are
just living like as if they're
sleepwalking is it that
you know i talk in one chapter about
the unlikeliness of any of us being
alive any of us actually being here
right now on earth and how just to just
to be who we are the odds against it are
like eight trillion to one and i mean
even more than that and but people
aren't thinking about this they're
they're not aware
of the awesomeness
of just the fact of being alive of the
cosmos as it evolved as as things on
earth evolve the way they are and so
i'm kind of
i'm kind of angry
a little bit about how
about how people are just
not aware of this that anger again
that's you know one of the things i did
as a clinician is to help people find
their purpose was to to help them find
out what they're angry about it's like
well what's your problem you know you
say that what's your problem but
actually you want to know it's like
because if you have a problem
then because there's lots of things you
could be bothered about but you're not
bothered about by all of them
right there's something that stands out
for you as you know something that
violates your sense of moral propriety
let's say that's your problem you think
well i don't want to have a problem it's
yes you do
you want to have your problem and then
you want to go try to solve it and if
you're looking for meaning in your life
it's like well what bugs you well i'm
annoyed at this and that and you know
it's pretty
naive and low resolution and formulaic
to begin with but you could zero right
in on that and then you find the purpose
of your life
and that's it that's in that anger it's
in that anger at least to some degree
yeah and as i said i can't write without
it i don't know why every day i have to
feel a little bit a little bit of pinch
of it or like a little bit of edge of
that knife in me
and and sometimes you know you have to
be that's right i mean i find when i'm
sitting down to write a chapter because
it's hard to sit down and and write a
chat there's a lot of work man and you
know writers always whine about that but
it is hard to it's hard to do it's as
hard as clinical work which is the
hardest work i ever did and so but i
have to be it's like there has to be a
reason for this
you know to get me going to do it it has
to be important and that means it has to
be dealing with something weighty and if
it's weighty it's gonna it's gonna
act it's gonna what what what's gonna
call out of you all your emotional
responses including the well certainly
including anger certainly that's a
tremendous form of energy
well i don't know if you have the same
experience but i read so many books uh
from my research etc and that's the main
thing that i fault them with there
there's no kind of energy behind it
there's no human behind it there's no
voice
that's kind of screaming out why did
they have to say
screaming out is exactly right that's a
great book screams like solzhenitsyn
school like archipelago that's like 3
000
pages of
screaming anger it's like you suspecting
screaming anger for three feet
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable it's
like being caught in a windstorm reading
that book yeah
and that's that greatness is terrifying
yeah yeah and that's that's kind of
channeling the dark side in some ways
yeah
yeah well i mean that man brought down a
totalitarian state at least in part it's
like you have to have a lot of force and
you think that it's not going to be
anger in part to to push back against
that's all that kind of petty tyranny
that you were talking about in it's in
its most
what would you say most rigidified and
universal form
and one man you know who decided he was
going to tell the truth and
and and and harnessed that passion to
his words changed the world
yeah yeah
so i don't know if i'll have that kind
of effect i'm sure i won't but um
that sort of i want people to
i kind of want to spark a sense of
almost the religious awe without an
organized religion behind it
because i think
we have changed a lot in thousands of
years but
there's something in our nature that
kind of craves
those kinds of experiences and nothing
in our culture is providing it it's the
definition of crave i don't think
nothing music does
yeah music does man music does and that
music was such a mystery for me when i
was a young psychologist like music is
meaningful and you can't argue the
meaning away
like it's it's invulnerable to criticism
isn't that so cool that there's a source
of meaning that's invulnerable to
criticism and then it's this harmonious
interplay of beautiful patterns
predictability and unpredictability and
and and the integration of passion and
movement right because because it
compels movement
you see think of people dancing to
astros waltz right they're harmonizing
themselves with the sublime patterns of
the world that's music
it's something man and it's no wonder
young people are so desperate for music
because that's where we have the sublime
in our culture
well that's where they go to things like
raves or astral worlds and concerts like
that they want that kind of collective
experience you know that you used to get
from like initiation rituals or kind of
things in pagan times i remember once i
was in
nicaragua i was a journalist i was
covering the
the civil the revolution the civil war
going on
and the pope was visiting nicaragua at
the time it's 1984 i believe
and there was
like a hundred thousand people crammed
in this one square
and you know i'm not by any means of
sandinista i had no sympathy for
particularly as it is now
but the feeling was that i experienced
i've never experienced anything else
like it of that crowd and that group
emotion it can be frightening too
yeah something we can think about like
well
well that's it that's the thing that
nazis were unbelievably good at at
pulling bringing that up right and so
you might say too that if we can't
figure out how to harness that force in
a positive way in our culture we pretend
it doesn't exist it's going to come up
in these underground ways because the
craving for it is so deep and the nazis
were masters of spectacle and fire
they were really good at that sort of
thing and orwell was courageous enough
to point that out he said well we don't
have anything with that power to combat
that terrible dramatic evil but if you
do see it in a concert you do see it in
that in that collective well you said
you saw it in relationship to the pope
and that's well hopefully that's
something good or at least it's
certainly a lot better than nuremberg
yeah
and to think that we don't need that or
that that's just superstition that's
extraordinarily naive yeah i know i know
i agree
yeah yeah well look it was really good
talking with you man very nice talking
to you i really enjoyed it these are
things i never get to cover in all of my
you know hundreds of interviews so i'm
very very grateful for it
i've explored territory that i've never
explored before so thank you oh isn't
that fun
yeah yeah yeah yeah unusual experience
for me yeah i really must i enjoyed it a
lot man yeah sorry
your maps of meaning was a very
important book for me i read it actually
to help me with my war book believe it
or not your notion of conflict
and integrating internal conflict and
external conflict so i just want to
thank you and let you know nobody knows
about that because i haven't really
spoken about it but that book was very
important for me
well thank you i'm amazed you read it
it's a hell of a slog that book six
seven hundred pages and i can't honestly
say i don't think i understood
everything in it at least at the time
but it was very amazing book
well thank you very much i'm glad to
hear that and yeah it took me i wrote
that book took a lot of anger man i
wrote that book every day three hours a
day every day for 15 years jesus
sure
yeah i had to put my hands around my
neck and say you sit goddamn it you sit
down write this goddamn book i had to
quit drinking i had to quit having fun
i know believe me i know all about that
it took me five years to write my last
book i can't imagine what 13 years would
be like but yeah i know all about that
well good luck with your book on the
sublime i'm looking forward to it let's
talk thank you very much let's talk
again when it when well
but maybe when it comes out that would
be good i really liked it and i'm really
curious about how you integrate your
investigation of the lease in illustrion
mysteries i talked to some interesting
people about that recently i know i had
already written the piece when i heard
them speak and then i i changed some
things because i realized some things
i've written were inaccurate but what i
try to do in that is i try and i create
a character a woman who's going to the
mysteries and what it was like from her
first person account it's fictional but
i'm trying to actually you know give her
a history
during the the plague in the 1420s and
then going to the mysteries and what it
would feel like subjectively to be in
there
yeah i had a vision once that the the
shamanic experience was an antidote to
icy northern totalitarianism
you know so many people are going to the
jungle now to the amazon to use
ayahuasca and that sort of thing and
there's i mean and that's certainly that
drug use that hallucinogenic drug use
was tied up with those primordial
religions in some professions we don't
understand any of that even a little bit
no
and of course the illusioni mysteries
probably had that drug element as well
because the drink they had was either
mushrooms or aragon or or or opium poppy
seeds puppy
so yeah
it's been demonstrated that all kind of
pagan cultures had some kind of drug
thing going on and
yeah
so
all right well good luck to you writing
this book and uh thank you very much
talking to you and i certainly are much
more clear about you everything that
you've been doing i'm so glad i decided
to talk to you and yeah me too me too
yeah i hope i brought a little bit of
clarity there oh absolutely it was a
really good discussion yeah yes thanks
again thank you thank you so much again
say hello to your daughter i will i will
do that definitely okay yeah she's a big
fan and so is my producer eric
oh eric
is this eric yes this year oh i had no
idea
hey eric yeah
yeah big fan big big yeah well i was all
shorted out when i was reading uh the
daily laws i thought i don't know what
to do with this it's like it's this what
the hell's going on here
and eric he said well he really liked
your books and my daughter really liked
your interview and i thought well i'm
obviously missing missing something you
know and i did i didn't spend as much
time when i was deciding about this
conversation reading it
but i had some sense that maybe you were
doing a shadow investigation but i
wasn't clear about it so but they were
big defenders of you it's like oh that's
good to talk to him thank you eric thank
you i appreciate of course yeah of
course anything i can do for you thank
you
no eric why were why were why were these
books helpful to you
oh man
[ __ ] good question uh
that's tough um there's been
a few points in my life where so i i was
a fighter it was my first career choice
as a mixed martial arts fighter
um and so to me
knowing
like from reading the 48 laws of power
it's very similar to jiu jitsu so when i
got into business it was like
oh i've seen this behavior before
because i've read this book and i
understand this so it started as like a
a very interesting it started just as an
interest like oh this seems cool i think
i saw you on tim ferriss's show or
something like that
um and and and when i started to see
those things come into play it then like
completely hooked me and i got all the
rest of the books
and so it prepared you
yes yeah and and one of the things
robert that i like so much about what
you're doing is you're taking these
principles you're showing it throughout
history and you're giving examples of
how this plays out today and so it's
like across the entire spectrum of what
type of thinker is reading it
yeah you have to be the type of thinker
that's going to read which is in
everybody but
across that spectrum
everybody gets a little
exactly what they need to hear in it so
it makes it very practical you can then
go off and be very practical with it the
same thing there yeah that practical
yeah yeah well it's really important
like one of the things you learn as a
cognitive behavioral psychologist is
that you have to nail this down to
changeable behavior you know one of the
things i was always doing with my
clients was and i've recommended this to
people many times in my lectures is
find
find the largest unit of change that
you're actually willing to do like maybe
you won't clean up your room i stress
that's like well
will you move one thing off your desk
today one thing
just one
or if you can't do that because
sometimes clients would come back and
say i couldn't even move one thing i
said well
why don't you look at one thing and
think about moving it
and they're embarrassed because you know
they're so unable to perform this task
which is a simple task in some sense
that they're ashamed to admit where they
are to themselves but they can't move
forward i had one client this is so
funny he lived at home with his mother
and he shouldn't he was too old for that
and
his room was a complete bloody
catastrophe and he knew it and he was
probably mad at his mother for like
coddling him and and so
he was needed to vacuum the carpet so
the deal for the week was you go vacuum
that carpet and he brought the vacuum
cleaner into his room but he left it in
the doorway like on a slant and every
day for a week he had to walk over that
vacuum cleaner he wouldn't put it back
and he wouldn't bring it in his room and
and vacuum and that's a good example of
that underground resentment just think
how angry you have to be at your
situation
to put a vacuum cleaner you know it's
probably a middle finger to me too it's
like i'm not doing what that goddamn
therapist says you know that kind of
resentment but he he literally walked
over that damn vacuum cleaner for a week
you know and we talked a bunch about
that's like well what are you doing it's
like obviously you're angry like why
can't you do this what are you angry
about well man he
he was angry about plenty of things
let's put it that way
so yeah there's that practicality that's
real necessary to nail the highest to
the lowest and to get all that organized
all the way down to practical
implementable
uh can you commute with the work of
milton erickson
yes
uh what do you refer to specifically
i just all of his work i just i just
enamored with his work because his
ability to create change in his patience
and the strategies he would employ i
just think are so brilliant
you know i don't know i don't know if
he's respected in the field or not
anymore but i just thought his story
well all those my experience with all
those great clinicians was you're a fool
if you don't take what they knew
seriously i mean those people had a
reputation for a reason and there's you
know i i really learned a lot from the
great behaviorists i learned a lot from
the psychoanalysts from the rogerian
types like they all had their
they all had something to say the
behaviorists were great at decomposing
something complex into implementable
units man and the psychoanalysts were
great at high level
conceptualization archetypal analysis
you know the big story the big picture
yeah
so
hey eric maybe we'll keep that
discussion with you in the video
okay yeah i like that yeah yeah sorry
for cursing right away no that sounds
good that was perfect
[Music]
you